hello good evening and welcome to our
Sunday evening lecture series my name is
Susan Engel and I direct the adult
division in the Center for adult life
and learning and I'm so glad to see so
many of you with us this evening
before I introduce tonight's guest I
want to bring your attention to some
upcoming events in this series next week
we will be having an important
discussion on race relations with
congressman Charles Rangel bill Tatum of
the Amsterdam news and two judges who
founded an organization called Jews and
blacks in conversation also there are
still some tickets available for George
Plimpton Jackie Mason and Andy Rooney
who will be appearing in future weeks
and now for tonight the moment we've
been waiting for
as you can see c-span is filming this
evening so during the question and
answer part of this program we kindly
ask that you go to the mics in the
aisles to and to ask your questions our
guest has been called the funniest woman
in America by the Washington Post and
her bestsellers Metropolitan Life and
social studies have garnered rave
reviews hilarious unique on the mark
British Vogue called her the natural
successor to Dorothy Parker Metropolitan
Life and social studies can now be read
in a newly released anthology called the
Fran Lebowitz reader which along with
her wonderful new children's book mr.
chasse and Lisa sue meet the pandas
which by the way is not just for
children can be purchased after the
program outside this hall at a book
selling and signing ladies and gentlemen
please join me in giving a very warm
welcome to Fran lead
with
hi um as you were been informed that
c-span is filming this which is good
news I think for the c-span watchers but
probably better news than it is for you
here I think considering the makeup of
the present Congress this will be
refreshing change for them so I cannot
think of a less competitive situation
what I'm gonna do tonight is I'm not
gonna actually give a speech because
you'll have to write a speech or you'll
have to be a senator
I am neither I am too lazy to be the
first and join us to be the second so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to read a
little bit from this book which is
called the friendly puts reader which is
includes it's not actually an anthology
it's actually everything I ever wrote
it's more of an encyclopedia I wanted to
call it the friendly Woodson cyclopædia
but they decided to call it the friendly
was reader I guess to distinguish it
from the friendly was writer so I'm
gonna read a little bit from this and
then I'm gonna answer questions from the
audience in an entertaining fashion you
don't have to ask them in entertaining
fashion you do have to speak up though
apparently no I'm usually I'm not but
I'm kind of afraid to touch this I'm
going to be touching this down yeah
usually at the Y I'm not the shortest
person
now that this book is in a different
order I don't know where everything is
anymore so you'll have to kind of uh
let's see bear with me this piece and
I'm gonna read now is is called a diary
of a New York apartment hunter it's
slightly dated
so I'll just jack up the prices by about
50 times him and I sometimes I read this
in New York but I sometimes we did
outside of New York where it's generally
perceived to science fiction here you'll
realize that it's understated Friday
awakened to the crack of dawn by a
messenger of Barry this coming Sunday's
New York Times real estate section first
six apartments gone already spent an
additional spent a good 15 minutes
dividing the number of New York Times
editors into the probable number of
people looking for two-bedroom
apartments spent additional half-hour
wondering how anyone who has a paper to
get out every day could possibly have
time to keep up 1,100 friendships
realize this theory not plausible and
decided instead that the typesetters all
up in coops wood-burning fireplaces
wondered briefly why listings always
specify wood-burning fireplaces decided
that considering the prices they're
asking it's probably just a warning
device for those who might otherwise
figure what the hell and just burn money
called VF and acquired politely as to
whether anyone his extremely desirable
building had died during the night
replying the negative I just don't get
it it's quite a large building and then
when in it has died for months
in my tiny little building they're
dropping like flies made a note to
investigate the possibility that high
ceilings and decorative moldings prolong
life
momentarily chilled by the thought that
someone who lives in a worst building
that mine is waiting for me to die
cheered immeasurably by realization that
a nobody lives in the worst building
than mine and be particularly those who
are waiting for me to die Saturday
uptown to Lucca coop in venerable
Midtown building met real estate broker
in Lobby a Caucasian version of Tokyo
Rose she immediately launched into
description of all the respectably
employed people who are waiting in line
for this apartment showed me the room
first large Airy terrific view of
well-known discount drugstore two
bedrooms
sure enough kitchen sort of when I asked
why the president occupant had seemed
fit to cut three five foot high arches
out of the inside wall of the master
bedroom she muttered something about
cross ventilation when I pointed out
that there were no windows in the
opposite wall she ostentatiously
extracted sheaf of papers from her
briefcase and study them closely
presumably these contain the names of
all the Supreme Court justices who are
waiting for this apartment nevertheless
I pressed on and asked her what one
might do with three five hood high
arches one's bedroom wall she suggested
stained glass I suggest appears in the
living room and services on Sunday
she showed me two rooms to refer to as a
master bath I asked her where the slaves
bathed she wrestled her papers ominously
and showed me the living room again
I looked disgruntled she brightened and
showed me something called
a fun bathroom it had been covered in
fabric from floor to ceiling by someone
who obviously was not afraid to mix
patterns I informed her unceremoniously
that I never again wanted to be shown a
fun bathroom I don't want to have fun in
the bathroom
I just want to bathe my slaves she
showed me the living room again either
she just couldn't get enough of that
discount drugstore or she was trying to
trick me into thinking there were three
living room impudently I asked her where
one ate seeing as I had not been shown a
dining room and the kitchen was
approximately the size of a brandy
snifter
well she said some people use a second
bedroom as a dining room I replied that
I need the second bedroom to write in
this was a mistake
because it reminded her of all the
ambassador's to the UN on her list of
prospective tenants
well she said the master bedroom is
rather large listen I said I already eat
on my bed in a one-room rent-controlled
slum apartment I'll eat on the bed and
greatly priced high maintenance co-op I
want to eat at a table call me silly
call me foolish but that's the kind of
girl I am
she accorded me out of the apartment and
left me standing in the lobby as she
hurried off anxious no doubt to call
Henry Kissinger and tell him okay the
apartment was his Sunday spent the
entire day recovering from a telephone
call with the real estate broker who in
response to my having expressed
displeasure and having been shown an
apartment in which the closest thing to
a closet had been the living room said
well friend what do you expect for
thirty five hundred a month
he hung up before I could tell him that
actually to tell you the truth for 3500
a month I expected the Winter Palace
furnished
not to mention fully staffed Monday look
this morning at the top floor of the
building which I have privately
christened Uncle Tom's brownstone one
end of the floor slope sufficiently for
me to be able to straighten up and ask
why the refrigerator was in the living
room I was promptly put in my place by
the owner who looked me straight in the
eye and said because it doesn't fit in
the kitchen true I conceded taking a
closer look that is a problem
I'll tell you what though and this may
not have occurred to you but that
kitchen does fit in the refrigerator
why don't you try it I left before he
could act on my suggestion and repaired
to a phone booth mortality rate in VFS
building still amazingly low call to my
department listen today's paper was told
fixed raphy $100,000 replied that unless
Rembrandt had ruled on the walls
$100,000 wasn't a fixer fee it was war
reparations Tuesday that desperation get
the best of me and went to see an
apartment described as interesting
interesting generally means that it has
a skylight no elevator and throw throw
in those little bottles for free this
one was even more interesting than usual
because the broker informed me check
heroin had once lived here someone's
pulling your leg I told him Jack Kerouac
still living here
Wednesday ran into a casual acquaintance
on 7th Avenue
turns out he too is looking for a
two-bedroom apartment we compared notes
did you see the one with the
refrigerator in the living room he asked
yes indeed I said well he said today I
looked at a dentist's office in the East
50s a dentist's office I said was the
cheran still there no he replied but
there was a sink in every room it
sounded like a deal for someone called
real estate broker and acquired as a
price of newly advertised co-op amount
in substantial six figures what about
financing I asked financing she
shuddered audibly this is an all-cash
building I told her that to me an
all-cash building is what you put on
boardwalk or Park Place she suggested
that I look further uptown I replied
that if I looked any further uptown I'd
have to take karate lessons she thought
that sounded like a good idea
Thursday was shown co-op apartment a
recently deceased actor by now so
seasoned that I didn't bat an eye at the
sink in the master bedroom
assumed that either he was a dentist on
the side
or that it didn't fit in the bathroom
second assumption proof correct
couldn't understand why though you think
that there not being a shower in there
would elect plenty of room for a sink
real estate broker pointed out recent
improvements tangerine colored kitchen
appliances bronze mirrored fireplace a
fun living room told the broker that
what with the asking price the
maintenance and the cost of unimprovable
it there and still wear shoes on a
regular basis call VF again first the
good news a woman in his building died
then the bad news she decided not to
move thank you
I think um let's see I guess this is I
can read this no one's gonna see it this
piece which I have no idea where it is
I mean same
it's called pointers for pets same and I
have no interest in hearing from the
animal rights advocates since animal
rights is an oxymoron
well how does the phrase animal
responsibility strike you pointers for
pets I feel compelled by duty to begin
this discourse with what I actually
think of as a statement but will more
properly be construed as an admission I
do not like animals of any sort I don't
even like the idea of animals animals
are no friends of mine they are not
welcome in my house they occupy no space
in my heart
animals are off my list I will say
however in the spirit of qualification
that I mean them no particular harm I
won't fire animals if animals won't
bother me well perhaps I had better
amend that last sentence I won't
personally buy their animals
I do feel though that a play / EFT of a
good kind of something rare is an
affront to the serious diner and that
while I have frequently run across the
fellow who could indeed be described as
a broccoli and potatoes man I cannot say
that I have ever really taken to such a
person
therefore I might more accurately state
that I do not like animals with two
exceptions the first being in the past
tense at which point I like them just
fine in the form of nice crispy
spareribs and bass region penny loafers
and the second being outside by which I
mean not merely outside as an outside
the house but genuinely outside as an
outside in the woods or preferably
outside in the South American jungle
this is after all only fair I don't go
there
why should they come here the above
being the case that you then come as no
surprise that I do not approve of the
practice of keeping animals as pets not
approve is too mild
pets should be disallowed by law
especially dogs especially in New York
City
I have not infrequently verbalizes
sentiment and what now passes for polite
society and having barely been the
recipient of the information that even
if dogs should be withheld from the
frivolous there would still be the blind
and the pathologically lonely to think
of I'm not totally devoid of compassion
and after much thought I believe that I
have hit upon the perfect solution to
this problem let the lonely lead the
blind
the implementation of this plan would
provide companionship to one and a sense
of direction to the other without
inflicting upon the rest of the populace
the all-too-common spectacle of grown
men addressing German shepherds in the
respectful tones best reserved for
elderly clergymen and internal revenue
agents you animal lovers uninterested in
helping news dealers across busy
intersections we'll just have to see
companionship elsewhere if actual
friends are not within your grasp may I
suggest that you take a cue from your
favorite celebrity and consider
investing in a really good entourage the
advantages of such a scheme are
inestimable an entourage is indisputably
superior to a dog or even of course to
actual friends and will begin to pay for
itself almost immediately you do not
have to walk an entourage on the
contrary one of the major functions of
an entourage is that it walks you you do
not have to name an entourage you do not
have to play with an entourage you do
not have taken on ties to the vet
although the conscientious entourage
owner makes certain that his entourage
has at all of its shots you do of course
have to feed an entourage but this can
be accomplished in decent Italian
restaurants and without the bother and
mess of large tin cans and special
plastic dishes if the entourage
suggestion does not appeal to you
perhaps you should alter your concept of
companionship living things need not
enter into it at all George and silver
and Duncan Phyfe sofas make wonderful
companions as do all alcoholic beverages
and out of season fruits use your
imagination study up on the subject
you'll think of something if however you
do not think of something and animal
lovers being a singer li intractable lot
chances are that you won't I have
decided to direct the remainder of my
remarks to the actual pests themselves
in the hope that they might at least
learn to to support themselves with
dignity and grace if you are a dog and
your owner suggests that you were a
sweater
suggest that he wear tell if you have
been named after a human being of
artistic note run away from home it is
unthinkable that even an animal should
be obliged to share quarters with anyone
who cause a cat Ford Madox Ford dogs who
earn their living by appearing in
television commercials in which they
constantly an aggressively demand meat
she remember that in at least one Far
Eastern country they are meat if you are
only a burden to gilded cage count your
blessings
a dog who thinks he is man's best friend
is a dog who obviously has never met a
tax lawyer if you are an owl being kept
as a pet
I applaud and encourage your tendency to
food you were to be highly commended for
expressing such a sentiment and a little
it is an unforgivable and wistful effort
in the direction of whimsy no animal
should ever jump up on the dining room
furniture unless absolutely certain that
he can hold his own in the conversation
thank you
um I don't think I have to read you
anymore you look like you know how to
read yourself and this is not always the
case I assure you so I think I will
answer your questions now in an
entertaining fashion there apparently
are microphones in the audience I don't
see them but I'll take their word for
them so anyone who wishes to answer a
question can just go up to microphone
those of you who want to shout a
question out I will repeat it for the
benefit of high technology yes what do
you think of Bill Clinton and how much
worse do you think the likely Republican
nominee of 496 will be like for example
a Bob Dole a Phil Gramm question was
what do I think of Bill Clinton and how
much worse do I think the likely
Republican nominee will be which he
seems to think will be Bob Dole I think
is optimistic
yes it's true that I think that whoever
his Republican nominee will be worse not
that I'm really a particularly big bill
clinton van but naturally we would
certainly prefer him to anyone that they
will run because I have noticed myself I
mean I've always been a Democrat but I
haven't always actually thought the
other party we're Republicans I no
longer think that these are not
Republicans a Republican is Nelson
Rockefeller you know I people forgot
we're Republican is just a rich person
who doesn't want to pay capital gains
taxes that's acceptable this is not this
is not republicanism this is
fundamentalism this is this is far her
worst if they would kind of stick to the
capital gains taxes which let's face it
doesn't affect us we wouldn't mind so
much we're used to that and you know
they also those Republicans also build
museums and these Republicans have never
been to a museum
this is just this is just sheer meanness
without money
this is know blessed Noah bleed this is
dangerous
and now we have a Republican mayor who
is kind of like it's like the Spanish
Inquisition here again isn't it
I mean it's become you may not be that
worried about it but I'm particularly
concerned about the I know smoking law
we have now coming up two restaurants I
think it's really important that we have
Family Values in New York um I didn't
come to New York for that I left
tomorrow's down no one lives here for
the quality of life
people move here to get away with stuff
they can't get away with in there I'm
not paying all this money to live in a
very noisy very expensive very densely
populated suburb you know so that I'm
yes I'm very appalled I would say
appalled by the new Republicans this is
not a slur the magazine in the same name
it's very disturbing although I don't
think my bill is going to be the nominee
I think it's gonna be worse than that I
think it's gonna be Phil Gramm I think
if someone who's gonna make Bob Dole
look like your fondest dream but I'm not
in charge and I have only once or twice
voted for anyone who won so I feel that
people should kind of instead of
worrying about New Hampshire they should
kind of keep track of friend
and I I'm an I don't want to brag but
I'm a superb voter I have voted in every
single election that I was eligible to
vote in even school board elections
where I've seen it none of you I know
that because I'm the only the only
person they're voting in their school
board elections somehow my parents
although they failed in certain respects
managed to instill in me the notion that
if I did not vote in every single
election I would have to go back to
Russia and live in a ghetto so I may be
kind of remiss in certain respects but I
am a hella boater
I'm just not accurate any other
questions say I think it's probably
inhibiting people having to walk up to
the microphone means the shire audience
members or the ones that are in the
midst you can tell me a question I'll
repeat it well the question was wasn't I
just in LA observing the OJ Simpson
trial no no um I was here observing the
ovations in trial I don't think anyone's
actually observing the OJ Simpson trial
I mean that's like kind of saying aren't
you observing the weather it's it's
really it's it I would say the way to
describe their distance in trouble trial
and one word would be unavoidable it is
impossible to avoid the OJ Simpson trial
you would actually think that this was
news I mean say you were from Venus yeah
and you came here and you just took a
look at the newspapers and flipped
through the television channels you
would think that this was the most
important event in the history of the
world instead of what is a crime that is
certainly committed hourly even in New
York
probably even with all our family values
and everything so I know I was not
observing the OJ Simpson trial
I would like to observe the end of the
OJ Simpson trial I tell you that or I
also have noted down that if I ever want
to kill anyone or let me amend that if I
ever give in to my impulse to kill
anyone
I certainly have every intention of
doing so in Los Angeles
we're by the way you also cannot smoke
any more questions the previous
questioner is confusing you with Annie
Leibovitz
um but yet she's them taller and richer
and not as good a reader yes but I don't
believe that she's observing the trial I
think she's just taking pictures that's
not really a form of observation you've
been fooled yes I believe that any
what's is what has been allowed into the
courtroom by the very proper and
decorous judge ito isn't he a
disappointment didn't at first you think
he was gonna be a good judge and then he
turned out to be just like the lawyers
and then of course you know I said to
myself what are you stupid of course he
was a lawyer first that's a problem with
judges CSI that believes she's taking
pictures and I believe they will be
appearing if not on the cover of The New
Yorker which is certainly a possibility
inside the New Yorker the new New Yorker
yes the New Yorker
yes
so the question was so what do I think
about the new New Yorker I think that a
picture of OJ Simpson on the cover is a
good idea I think there just be like you
know that's accommodate economy they now
have between the cover and the inside
like where they will be attracting the
buyers who will not read it and
repelling the readers who will not buy
it talk about your experiences why you
decided to write a children's book and
what it was like for you and what your
next ideas are on a three-part question
I talk about what these why I wrote a
children's book what the experience was
like and what my next ideas are these
are unrelated questions for them
I read the children's book just because
I had always wanted to write a
children's book and I thought it'd be
good I needed to do something I always
wanted to do before I died and this is
what became available to do the
experience if it was like no other
experience of writing I've ever had by
which I mean I finished the book because
it was a pleasurable experience the only
problem with it was just having to think
up stuff which I never had to do before
since it had a story to it so I actually
found myself a woman of middle years
sitting at a desk thinking now what do
the pandas do
and so that made it unusual experience
and the other aspect of the seniors
appearances I now receive letters from
children which are nicer than the
letters used to hinder and to which I
replied and also it would usually come
with pictures and then they always have
a little thing please write back and so
I often do and that's been an
entertaining experience one of the
letters I got from a little boy who was
obviously did not want to give me his
home address so I had to write back to
micariff Dalton and he felt that there
was a problem with the ending of the
book he said mr. Chow's and lisa sue me
the pen is is interesting but it stops
short period so I wrote back to this
child and at the bottom I said I trust
that upon completion of your education
you are not considering a career in
literary criticism but as possible that
he already is working say at the New
Yorker
he suggested that I write a sequel
because he felt I had left the reader
hanging he felt this was inadvertent
so he must have just been visiting
Dalton so I'm I'm writing a another
children's book it was meant to be a
series I mean it still is meant to be a
series other than that I don't really
have any ideas yes the question is doing
I think it's somewhat hypocritical that
I hate animals and I'm writing about
pandas I know I don't
first of all these aren't real pandas
although you can be sure that I've heard
from a great many panda experts pointing
out to me all the mistakes I've made in
depicting panda life people that they're
very we have a great number of penned
experts we have I don't know if you know
this very few pandas something I didn't
know I just used pandas because pandas
occurred to me of course they could have
been any sort of animal and I don't
really know anything about animals I'm
not familiar with Anamosa I didn't know
for instance that pandas were from China
nor did I know they were scarce I mean I
suppose I imagined that the hills of
Connecticut were filled with cavorting
pandas and so I used pandas pandas are
very very scarce but panda experts are
common and this is kind of the situation
we have I would say we have a like
number of panda experts and guidance
counselors in this country
and they all write letters and the Pend
experts informed me that pandas do not
eat pizza and that in fact that's you
may not others the major problem with
pandas is that they eat only bamboo and
there are not enough bamboo trees or
shrubs or whatever
I mean bamboo to me is kind of furniture
that people have outside but there's
enough bamboo furniture left for them to
eat and this is why we have too few
pandas the pen is in my book talk so I
think their eating habits are really not
important um I didn't I didn't mean to
give the impression that I was applying
to expert so I'd like to clear that up
so these pandas are not as animal like
if I must say I would be an animal lover
if animals were like this alright that
would if there if there were animals
such as this I would be happy to have
some animals myself if you know of any
talking pandas send them around yes
what books and magazines am i currently
reading and why well we have to make a
distinction here between books and
magazines books I actually seek out
magazines just come to the house I would
say that I get every single magazine if
not every single almost every single
magazine comes to my house by messenger
marked very urgent biggest it is
imperative that I get that first bad
issue of us so I I don't really read
magazines I kind of plow through the
bunch of stuff that's on the kitchen
table I skip through it I would say read
is not a word I would use to apply to
magazines the magazines are kind of the
bane of my existence they're the bane of
your existence too but you'll be be
unaware of it
I mean life would be a million times
better without magazines there's just no
I mean unless you know you love them
which we don't um but books I actually
seek out and I am
I'm a bookworm before you ask who my
favorite writer is I don't have a
favorite writer I have many favorite
writers which I usually will not list
because I went out for remember one or
two favorite writers and then someone
write me a letter and it won't be for
Dalton and it'll be nasty letter and I'm
a very promiscuous reader I read
everything I am a [ __ ] of literature I
really are we almost anything right now
I just spin it I just for some reason
because I asked him to send him to me
wanted to read Chester Himes was a
mystery writer who was a mystery writer
so I read them all in a row and that's
was the last thing I read the before
right before that I read a book called
Stalin Oedipus and Stalingrad which I
loved by a gregory bond with soaring and
snow for spent issue of us but i would
recommend it to you
no I don't read the newspaper you don't
have to read the newspaper you don't
have to because all day long people call
and read you stuff at the newspaper
I mean constantly people read I mean we
should really assign just one or two
people to read the papers I mean when
you think of the waste of time think of
it you're repeating the same action over
and over again I think maybe every day
three people should be assigned one to
read each one of the newspapers and then
they should call everybody up because
some I never read the paper I read the
Sunday Times sometimes otherwise I don't
read the newspapers but I believe I know
everything that's in the newspaper and I
think that if something really really
important happened my mother would call
and tell me because she called me with
the unimportant stuff so I hear that and
it's impossible to avoid the news is
unavoidable like OJ Simpson there must
be nothing in the newspapers I was in LA
I'll tell you that I when I was in LA a
couple weeks ago not observing the OJ
Simpson trial the LA Times is about
four-fifths OJ Simpson news including on
the front page I don't think that's
going on here
I mean in The Times I think it's
probably inside but it is basically all
the news that's there yes
question was how did I become a writer
and at what point did I discover myself
as a writer I don't know quite what you
mean by that
I decided I wanted to become a writer
when I was about five years old I just
didn't realize you had a right when at
the point in which I learned how to read
and then I learned that people wrote
books before I realized people wrote
books I thought the books were just here
like trees and I thought whoever was in
charge of making the trees made the
books now I have come back to that
opinion um but so when I realized that
people could write books I decided to
write books myself and the only other
career I never seriously considered was
I did have a brief flirtation with
wanting to be a toll taker this was a
child because my grandparents lived in
Connecticut we used to drive there and I
guess I associated 12 acres with a
glamour of travel and I thought this was
a great job you know they were uniforms
and that was glamorous that's glamorous
to all children as you can tell by the
people who then choose to wear them as
adults and I thought also that they kept
the money which I guess sometimes they
do so I wanted to be a call taker but
when I gave up the toll taking idea and
when I realized that there was very
little possibility that I was going to
be a Pope which is really what I'd like
to be and I realized it soon will be an
opening in the papacy I'm still
available to be the Pope but in case I
don't make that final cut that was the
thing that I most wanted to do because
as a child I still enjoyed writing so
that's why I wanted to be a writer
yes
I didn't hear the last party question
then what question was how could I go
about how would I go about making
education more fun and interesting for
kids why would I want to I think that
when education becomes fun as ceases to
be education I think clearly there
having enough fun but I would never
worry about kids having fun I would
worry it they can't read fun they'll do
on their own the last thing I think that
don't you worry about is providing fun
for children really I can't think of
anything more unnecessary than providing
fun for children and the fact is that
learning is not fun learning education
is work for children it's their job it's
like you know one guys run saying how
can we make the office more fun for the
adults no one worries about that so I
would not be worried about education
making education more fun for children I
would be worried about making it more
educational I would like to actually
have you know say a generation children
who know how to read I think that would
be much more helpful than having a
generation children who know how to
party yes yes
specialist can I say anything about Newt
Gingrich as a professor probably not
that hasn't been said already I don't
actually think of him as Professor
funnily enough I think he's someone for
whom education was made too much fun I
think he is probably you know he's Jerry
Falwell's idea of an intellectual I'm it
isn't like a real college or anything he
teaches that you know no it's some kind
of you know remember you played on
smoking remember those look like
matchbook cotton I think that's where he
teaches I don't think of a mr. professor
I don't think of him as a congressman I
think of him as a punishment from God
he's like the worst kid who was in your
class and now he's moved next door to
you like you thought you left him behind
no there he is it's um it's very
depressing it's it's uh at least he's
not in New York
I mean Giuliani is the New York version
Newt Gingrich you know he's just the
more prosecutorial version you know he's
more of an I mean I think David Dinkins
when he was running for mayor said the
exact right thing he said I'm running
for mayor he's running for warden and
now he made it and now he's a warden
I think what's what's really shocking is
that even the police commissioner who is
a Nazi it's too is too soft for Julia
how did he
China feels he's kind of slipping and
sliding too much you know he's angry and
he's not keeping it I didn't have a chip
it's been I would say that I'm not you
know I'm not giving exact statistics but
it seems to me that about every four
days the police shoot another person
here you know that was never the case
with New York cops before what I always
thought about New York cops were yes
well they take money yes well they can't
run they're too fat but at least they
don't shoot people but now they should
but not from a running position
yes yes what I think of television
compared to Newt Gingrich or listen to
this may without television we wouldn't
have Newt Gingrich I think television is
OK for adults but I don't think children
should be allowed to watch it you know
it's okay if you realize what it is what
you don't is a channel because it's a
child you think it's part of life if
you're as old as I am or even a little
younger and you have some idea that it's
separate from life I think that's all
right it's I think [ __ ] it only pizza
someone with a formed consciousness
should be exposed to it which means like
maybe 40 I actually might plan for
everyone would be that I think
everything should be illegal until
you're 40 and then everything again
illegal after you're 60 I think it
should be only 20 years where you can do
stuff really I mean driving for instance
no one should drive before the 40 I mean
they really I know once you drive that
for 60 there should be just those 20
years where you can drive because before
40 you're really too relaxed about your
own mortality and after 60 you can't see
so there's enough people between 40 and
20 between 40 SEC to do all the driving
and all the voting I mean for since I
wasn't really that much in favor of MTV
were houses to vote I wasn't so thrilled
to see those people voting I think they
should have to like say read a lot of
books before they can vote so 40 would
be good and then after 60 no you can't
vote anymore either so I think this
would be the best plan I'm 44 so I would
be only having to have a few more years
left to having to drive I would prefer
not to drive right now and if my plan
was in shape all those other people
would need jobs they could drive for him
so that's my plan yes
um could I kindly uh-huh
that's demanding I'm envision a future
without the NEA um I frankly could live
without the NEA you could too
I mean to me that that's not really it
doesn't concern me too much I mean there
is a limit to the number of fourth rate
dance troupes we need in this country I
would be in favor of DNA only if I was
in charge of it I would be in favor of
almost anything if they let me be in
charge of it you know people are saying
who would be the judge I would be the
judge I would actually like to be a real
judge I would like to be the Chief
Justice Supreme Court I am perfect for
this job
I am extremely judgmental and I make
snap judgments
so I'd move that court right along you
know the NA is it's not important it's
not important to it's important to the
ten people who get the $10,000 grants
it's not important to the cultural life
of this country there is no cultural
life in this country
it's only important as a symbol to these
kind of lunatic
you know fundamentalist ministers who
are now running the country as a symbol
and maybe it would be better if they
didn't have this symbol to show because
it's a fake
you know I don't think it's I just don't
think it's that serious one way or the
other
um I think the other things are doing a
far more serious I think there is this
notion now in this country I mean
basically whether what they're gonna do
and aside from taking away this is very
little money most of the things they
want to take the money away from are not
very much money so they're not you know
what welfare is not very much money
either if you went into the street you
asked anyone how much of your taxes you
think about welfare they say eighty
percent that's the idea and people are
costly saying these people and well
further I think with a kind of envy we
now live in a country where people envy
people and whatever I always try to
explain to people you know what it must
be like to be on welfare it must be like
having to renew your drivers license
every day having to go down to that
motor vehicle board every day and stand
in those lines and deal with those
delightful public servants that's what
it's like being on welfare except they
have to do it every single day so I
don't envy this I don't think I do you
think the NA is very important clearly
you do you don't you must get a grant um
you might be surprised I've never been
on these grant lists so um I never had a
personal connection to it but when I see
the people who receive these awards I'm
never that happy for them let's put it
that way yes literary heroes who are my
literary heroes I'm not really the hero
worship or you might imagine me to be
um don't really have heroes I mean you
know they're writers that quite like the
writers I admire there are writers that
I think that's about as high as I go I'm
it they're mostly dead
I prefer dead writers in every respect
you know first of all you know you don't
run into the parties and there are more
good dead ones and live ones
and this will always be the case I mean
the ones that are dead now are going to
be better than the ones that are dead
ten years from now there's been a
definite definite attrition in the
quality of writing naturally since of
course people have to read to in order
to be writers and people seem to skip
this part of it now they just go right
to writing school 21 years of MTV and
then Iowa then they write books but I
don't read those books so I don't really
have any heroes in the sense that you
assumed immediately I'm sorry to
disappoint you
yes
do I have any friends do I have any
friends who don't smoke and if they
don't what I do when I go to restaurants
with them or go to their homes if I do
there was I guess some hesitation the
idea that anyone might invite me into
their home I have many friends who don't
smoke I was here probably the majority I
would say if my friends don't smoke or
more than half I guess when they go to
restaurant with me they send the smoking
section when I go to their homes they
said mismo connection I must say I think
it's I first of all have to say that I
do not believe that me smoking a
cigarette in dangers or health that is
totally absurd why don't you worry about
the 57 treat bus I hope that you'll
stand in front of breathing that in but
if someone like to see we're next in a
restaurant you're hysterical it's like
you know you can't smoke in any
restaurant on California you know when
you when you land at any city in
California you see the state is
blanketed by this orange gunk 25 feet
deep
that ain't cigarette smoke that's from
the cars you know cars people should
worry about that second answer red smoke
I would not go to someone's house if you
know how to smoke in the house I would
want to even know someone who didn't let
you smoke in the house I think what
people really have done is people are
annoyed by other people cigarette smoke
that's annoying I'm annoyed by the
people cigarette smoke other people are
annoying
did your mother ever tell you that it's
not just their cigarette smoke that's
annoying I mean just basically they're
annoying yeah I mean how would you like
the 7 o clock the morning be sitting
next to a guy on an airplane who is
drenched in aftershave lotion that's
really annoying you know I mean that's
what public means being annoyed by the
habits of others
otherwise you can stay home in your
smoke-free environment I must say people
who are so worried about you know air
quality
what are you doing living in New York to
begin with you know you should move to
an alpine village yes
I don't even remember doing that but I
take her word for it she said I
described these times is being dealt
with probably I meant in comparison to
the time and say when I was 25 that's
kind of self-explanatory isn't it I mean
everybody in New York always says how
much better New York was 20 years ago
they usually start saying that when
they're around 40 and it's true New York
is always better 20 years ago it doesn't
matter when the 20 years ago were it's
just that they always in New York was
always better 20 years ago and I'm sure
that that's true I twenty years from now
we might say was better than if we're
lying so that's what I meant by it I
mean it was a more fun it's more fun to
be 25 than it is to be 44 maybe even
outside New York but New York certainly
was in general it seems to me more fun
than four numbers of reasons for in
smoking it's one of them um
rampant promiscuity was another one you
know its before I you know was before
AIDS it was before Puritanism before
prohibition it was just more fun it was
more wide open so that's that's what i
meant by more fun
there's also was less media which always
is cause for merriment and because there
was covert life in New York you could
actually people did things went places
and it wasn't in the newspaper than
attracting a billion other people you
know also New York was more new Yorkish
it ho now for instance I don't know if
you've all noticed a change in 57th
Street from 57th Street to Anaheim East
you know so now that it's just like you
know Disneyland you know there's all
these Hard Rock Cafe New York didn't
have chains New York was New York you
know I mean there was no McDonald's
there on all these suburban
change what we now have is kind of
suburbanization of New York's of New
York from a point of view of sensibility
but with none of the advantages of
suburban life in other words it's still
noisy is still filthy is still really
expensive and now it's born
you know obviously not we all here
decided to put up with all the bad stuff
it was to get something you know I feel
like hey where's the thing we came here
to get that's what I mean by alignment
don't yes the question is what ever
consider living anywhere else by New
York or have I ever considered well I
used to say that you know I didn't ever
consider it because you know New York
was too much fun and then I said I did
never consider it because I didn't think
I'd be allowed to live anywhere else now
I don't feel like I'm allowed to live
here um so I might consider it if you
could think of like a really fun place
Paris the down the problem with parents
is you know they speak French
I am monolingual yes
do people often confide in me and if so
is it tempting to use your secrets and
stories unfortunately people
continuously can fight Ameen it isn't
even tempting to listen to them let
alone to use their secrets and stories
which unfortunately by the time you're
40 for it you've already heard about
eight billion times I mean I would be
interested if someone did something
really different but so far no one has
so no it's not it's not tempting to me
if you mean from point of view of
material the fact is that if you've
really lived as hard as I have and
written his little materials not a
problem I'm not really worried about
running out of material I mean it went
when Rose Kennedy died someone said can
you imagine she was 104 what would you
do if you lived to be 104 and I said
well maybe I'd finished two books so I'm
not it's not tempting to me to use other
people's longings for material yes what
are my thoughts on from yelp Aglio I
don't feel that really the word thought
is what's appropriate here I'm not
really interested very much by her
there's someone at my publisher who was
very interested by her and thrust her
last book upon me and just a few days
ago I kind of read through it and it was
kind of like reading one of those first
bound issues of us you know except a
little more ambitious I don't I don't
know I don't find her interesting you
know I I find her well for a friend of
mine described it as she's writing about
a party that ended 20 years ago - which
was never invited to begin with I find
her let's put it this way small town
i scorn its you know it's kind of um I
think it doesn't she teach you the same
College Newt Gingrich teaches that yes
you know no one's ever asked me that
before where was I when President
Kennedy died that I would say that would
be my favorite question except that
during the Iran hostage situation I was
asked in San Francisco who was my
favorite hostage
I was on a school bus I was in junior
high school and I got on a school bus
and the bus driver stood up and he was
crying and he said children I have
terrible news for you President
Roosevelt has been shocked that's what
actually happened and then I was the
only one of the best who knew who
Roosevelt was so I said what do you mean
he's dead already so I was in charge of
that bus as you could say
yes no because you'll see that they have
something in common
absolute power you know and it's better
that people who have these desires are
Pope's or Supreme Court justices as
opposed to say writers oh I see no
inconsistency what it's a very similar
job you know I mean the clothes are
better if you're Pope otherwise I think
it's close yes I didn't hear the
beginning what you said she doesn't yet
have a beach house this is for the yes
perhaps you'd like to know who my
favorite hostages the question was she
does not yet have a beach house and I
don't know I mean know whether you mean
yet this season or yet in your lifetime
of this season I have never had to be
challenged
my advice is it's much better to have a
friend who has a beach house than to
have a beach house in fact I would think
this is true of any house at all the
thing that I have learned in my life
after I bought my apartment which was
absolutely without a doubt the stupidest
thing I ever did in my life um was that
I have the soul of a renter then I was
never meant to own anything I don't want
to own anything I have no interest in
owning anything because I have such in
my own life such a long tradition of
hating the landlord that it just hating
the co-op board isn't the same any other
questions yes sorry
yes
does my writing get edited much and if
so does it bother me no one is allowed
out of me so it doesn't by the middle
I've never um I don't understand editing
Franklin
I mean I'm gonna talk about magazine
writing or newspaper writing or
something like that which is just really
information but I don't even know what
it means and no other art form is this
even a possibility someone would go into
a painter studio and say no hello
I mean you know I think it's too much of
a free ride you know I mean if editors
want to write let him stay home and
write you know I mean they have the best
of all possible worlds they get to
change someone else's writing they have
an office of salary ya know it's not
fair no so it doesn't bother me at all
because I've never allowed it yes or I
think of Gloria Steinem as what as a
writer I never thought of it I mean I
never thought about her as a writer I
mean I think of her more as a I don't
know media figure I think she's okay I'm
not that familiar with her work I mean I
know of course who she is I think she's
fine
yes
really in what way
you must think I can't see you from here
I can't think of any way in which I'm
similar to Wendy Wasserstein except you
know there probably wouldn't be people
say in 1936 in Germany who might have
thought there were similarities so I'm
not familiar with this piece that you're
ready I don't really read those
magazines yes do I believe in the
afterlife I don't even believe in this
life
you know I just really rarely listen to
music I mean it's not that I don't like
it I just never think of listening to it
I don't know why this is I've never
owned any well keeps changing but I
initially never owned a stereo now I
don't own a CD player who knows what I
won't own in the future the only time I
ever listen to music really is I mean I
said on silent I have a tape player
whatever you called me I was but
sometimes I listen to it but usually
I'll only send music when I'm driving
which is to distract me from the fact
that I have to drive so I used to a lot
go to hear a jazz when they were still
enough jazz musicians alive but now
there aren't there two of you so I'm not
really I'm not what you call a music
expert so I don't know yes I have no
idea how do I go about writing when I do
write well unfortunately I've discovered
that you actually have to sit at the
desk
not even every year no if you do it
every day those pages pile up too much
yes how quickly didn't my toes book I'm
not sure because I wrote it along with
the novel I'm writing and I didn't have
to seek out the Advisory children I am
very childish I don't even have to
remember my childhood its present in me
at all times so I didn't have to ask any
children what they thought of it I have
people ask me that's a funny question to
ask I mean no one I guess people feel
that children are such a different
species from adults that you would have
to ask that question I was a child
I remember my own childhood I'm as angry
as a child was and I feel as powerless
and I don't have an allowance so that
would be impetus enough to write a
children's book yes thank you are you
sure you wouldn't rather know who my
favorite hostages what's my position on
the Jewish tradition I don't even know
what that question means I really don't
know what it means
it means not being a Gentile
that's what it means to me I mean
obviously I I'm not a practicing Jew but
I don't feel you have to I think it's
funny that would use always worried you
know that Jews urn of Jews identifying
themselves as Jews I always thought that
was a job of the Gentiles you know I
don't I don't think it's I don't think
you just have to worry about that let's
put it that way yes but single human
quality do I respect the most I'm trying
to even think of a human quality um I I
really I don't know what you mean by
that what do you mean character trait or
I think someone who's a good listener
that's the character trait I most of my
arm yes well I have gambled in my life
I'm not really a gambler in other words
I'm not addicted to it if that's what
you mean
I have gambled in my life I play the
lottery sometimes and I expect to win
every time I play and I expect to when
every time I don't play because you have
the same chance
so I checked those numbers no matter
what and I don't think the numbers are
enough I think there should be a name I
think they should say the numbers and
then say head friend that's you but I'm
not so much worried about winning the
letter anymore because I don't really
want to brag but I turns out that I'm
one of the six top contenders for the
New York in New York for the publishing
Clearing House I've been notified by
mail my name is right there with five
other people's names from New York but
I'm mine my name is circled so I have
this ten million on the come from the
publishing clearing out so I'm not
really that worried about winning the
lottery anymore
yes premier you
for me it was work for you it was
entertainment she asked what it was like
to be on David Letterman really being on
TV is is is I mean it's maybe a little
different on each TV show I mean that
show was particular cuz Prince was on so
it's a very exciting backstage but it's
pretty much the same you're on for about
30 seconds if you're writer you know
you're on the end you're on very quickly
and you hardly you don't even notice
you're on you know they ask you two
questions that's it you have to go back
to New York
it seems really always to be very
similar experience to me is what I mean
because it's very it's very short its
brief
it's very artificial it's just like
really yes what do I think of different
you mean I don't know him I really I
don't know David Letterman I've been on
the show very frequently but I've only
seen him while I'm on the show so if you
watch this hour you know much better
than I do you know I mean I only seem
for those like seven minutes that I'm on
the show so I don't really have a
personal opinion of him I'm glad he has
a show yes could I tell you a little
about my family childhood I have a
mother a father a younger sister who's
taller than me and who has been taller
than me since I was about 11 I think I
pretty much sums it up
I mean she's a lot taller than me yes
for my favorite comedians well my
favorite comedian was Richard Pryor
until he got burned up and then he
became grateful to be alive which is a
very poor position for a comedian to be
in but before he got burnt up and became
too grateful to be alive he was by far
the best stand-up I ever saw you know I
never saw a Lenny Bruce
so everyone says he was better but I
never saw him but he was by far the best
but I think that there are a lot of
great stand-up comedians I could watch i
watch those TV shows that are on at 3
o'clock the morning to have a thousand
comedians in a row they're never enough
for me there could be 10,000 comedians
in a row there are there are more good
stand-up comics than any and you know
then there are people good in any other
field I mean if you took the ratio of
how many good senators there are
compared to how many good stand-up
comics there are there's no contest
so there really are great many Stan
comes that I like of course I can't
think of their names no yes Peggy Noonan
she's not my favorite Stan I'm coming
I mean Peggy Noonan I know she was a
speechwriter for Ronald Reagan and when
I voiced some objection to her presence
somewhere someone said that I was being
unfair friend you're being unfair after
all all she did was write his speeches
and I said well he did was make speeches
no I'm not a reagan fan and next
question yes compared to Peggy Noonan
naturally I've always been a big darn a
Parker Pen I did receive recently a
letter from a 13 year old girl and some
place like La Jolla or Santa Monica or
something saying that she see me on TV
she thought I was really funny she read
my book she thought it was funny this
book not the children's book and then
she she read that I was like Dorothy
Parker so she went to see the Dorothy
Parker movie and she was extremely upset
to then see me on the Jay Leno Show
because I look nothing like Jennifer
Jason Leigh and you're worried about
education not being fun for the kids